vladimir est étudiant en master 2 à
paris dauphine il n'imaginait pas finir
ses études dans de telles conditions
ce changement radical avec le début de
son cursus a été difficile à vivre dans
la fois que j'étais en cours c'était le
22 octobre
on était sur un système semi
présidentiel semi distant ciel dès
septembre que j'ai pu me préparer un peu
tout ça mais les débuts quand on est
passé en distancier de total sa a été
c'est compliqué parce qu'on perd le
contact avec les autres
on perd le contact aussi avec les
enseignants et sur une année comme celle
du master 2 c'est calme assez compliqué
parce que c'est une année où on a besoin
de beaucoup de soutien
j'ai vu des passages à vide
j'en ai vu un aussi d'ailleurs ça fait
un mois et demi on était au coeur du
confinement en fait et c'est vrai que là
la solitude commencé à se sentir si
aujourd'hui son moral va mieux c'est en
partie grâce à l'un des responsables de
son master qui lui a donné des conseils
pour mieux s'organiser au quotidien mais
ce manque de lien avec les autres
camarades sur ressent aussi sur le
travail
j'ai senti que ça joue sur la cohésion
de la promotion parce qu'en fait
finalement on se connaît moins comment
ce qu'on est moins on sait moins
forcément comment les autres
fonctionnent et ça peut créer des
tensions notamment dans les travaux de
groupe pour lui qui est en fin d'études
l'insertion dans le monde du travail est
une grande source d'inquiétude pour
valider les masters on doit aussi avoir
un stage est là en ce moment pour avoir
des stages c'est compliqué les
entreprises nous disent qu'elles
prennent pas de stagiaires à cause du
coc vide on sait pas non plus quels
seront les débouchés sur l'emploi après
donc c'est très compliqué louis étudiant
en première année de cinéma vit dans un
campus
il a donc davantage de proximité avec
d'autres jeunes de son âge
je suis un petit appartement mais ça
fait au final comme s'ils s'étaient
plaints d'appartements dans un grand
immeuble on se fait rapidement des potes
on sort un peu le soir on en limitant
collier dame nature mais non son
entre on travaille ensemble et puis
enfin franchement c'est bon c'est bon
enfant et c'est cool
malgré cette proximité il était loin de
s'imaginer un tel début de vie étudiante
alors mes études avant j'ai imaginé
vraiment mode faire la fête tout le
temps et j'ai imaginé vraiment c'était
c'était ça et c'est ce qui me plaisait
aussi dans les études c'est cette part
désir bon c'est hyper festif sont ça y
est on a la majorité on va faire plein
de trucs on va on va vraiment vivre nos
années nous années 20 à quoi bon c'est
très limité du coup les psychologues
observe une hausse de nouveaux patients
chez les étudiants louis n'en fait pas
partie mais pour certains de ses amis
d'un situation est différente
alors non je veux pas voir de 2-1 après
j'en parle beaucoup avec les amis sur
tous mes amis qui sont sur la côte vers
ronan tout ça c'est sûr que c'est un
sujet car ce qui revient assez souvent
surtout j'ai des copains en paces et
pour eux c'est l'horreur et franchement
je me compare à eux et je me dis je suis
vraiment dans une bonne situation
face aux difficultés que rencontrent les
étudiants emmanuel macron a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures
il souhaite le retour des étudiants au
moins une journée en présentiel par
semaine et il affirme que les boursiers
et non boursiers pourront désormais
manger deux fois par jour au restaurant
universitaire pour un euro